Дорогі
колеги на цьому заході по-перше хотів би
привітати колег з першим дм весни Я знаю
і розумію прекрасно що це величезний
оптимізм для нас для всіх тих хто
розраховує на великі обсягиі
фінансування науки в 2017 році ми зі
свого боку сподіваємося на перегляд
бюджету 17-го року в частині збільшення
обсягів підтримки наших вищих навчальних
закладів е-е для це би хочу сказати що
разом із комітетом ми робимо все що
залежить від нас для того щоб підтримати
реформу Міністерства освіти і зокрема
закону України про
науково-науково-технічну діяльність ми
обговорювали усім науковим загалум
протягом е останніх кількох років і
маємо В кінцевому е випадку досить
солідний результат звичайно НЕП не
підкріплює тим обсягом фінансів який
хотілося відповідно до обсягу ВП але
зрештою У нас є документ який дозволяє
нам сьогодні бути максимально мобільними
самостійними неопередженими в своїй
професійної діяльності по-друге На
порядку денному стоїть максимальне
зближення закону украримі провищо освіту
з потребами його перегляду тому ее
рівень його імплементації Я так само
думаю будемо обговорювати разом із вами
максимально наближувати його до
європейських стандартаів по-третє за
ініціатива нашого комітету за підтримки
Міністерства освіти 16-му році вперше за
останні роки ми провели виставку кращих
наукових розробок академічних установ і
Великої академії галозевих академій наук
і ми відкриті до підтримки цього 17-го
року щоб відкрити двері не тільки
Верховної Ради але й збільшити Поло
друзів е-е наукових установ класичних
університетів особливо напередодні е
перегляду у бюджету чим більше наших
прихильників Чим більше людей у
Верховній Раді поділяє Принципи розвитку
української науки як науки космічної як
науки сучасної як науки перспективно Я
думаю тим більше у нас шансів і
можливості зберегти і наукові школи і
залучити якомога більше молодих людей до
науки до наших наукових шкіл і від себе
і від комітету хотів би подякувати
міністерству за те що є гарна ініціатива
створення музею науки в
Києві Я думаю що вона на часі бо однієї
малої Академії Наук недостатньо
недостатньо Національної академії наук
питання популяризації питання
відкритості наукових розробок доступу до
кращих досягнень вони повинні
обгорюватися вони повинні ставати
стимулом для того щоб молодь працювала
над цим для того щоб молодь залишалася в
Україні наїжджала і робила все для того
щоб українська наука українське
суспільство було не тільки боєздатним не
тільки інтелектуально підготов м але і
звичайно забезпеченим необхідними
ресурсами я бажаю сьогодні кожному
класичному університету представникам
гідного захисту знаєте що комітет освіти
і науки завжди до ваших послуг ми
працюємо на вас і сподіваємося на вашу
ку